tha
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat hier le sénat a adopté
une proposition de loi du groupe rdse
qui vise à renforcer l'éthique dans le
sport
ce texte a été adopté à l'unanimité
moins l'abstention du groupe communiste
et parti de gauche
chantal jouanno ministre des sports a
apporté son soutien à ce texte violence
drogue spéculation le sport n'est pas
exempte de dérive at elle reconnu
c'est donc l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi que je vous propose
de suivre est tout de suite très bonne
matinée à tous la séance s'est reprise
nous allons examiner les articles de la
proposition de loi
je rappelle que le titre premier porte
sur le respect des valeurs du sport et
nous en arrivons donc à l'article 1er et
c'est notre collègue claude de mai elle
qui va nous présenter l'amendement
numéro 8
merci monsieur le président madame amis
sont mes chers collègues je ne pense pas
me tromper en affirmant que sur tous nos
bancs nous sommes attachés aux principes
d'unité et de ce lien de solidarité du
mouvement sportif
car c'est bien ce lien fondamental entre
sport amateur et sport professionnel qui
est au fondement de notre système
sportive et fait sa spécificité
pour notre part nous considérons que ce
principe fondateur ne peut être absent
des chartes éthiques des fédérations
sportives tout particulièrement dans une
période où certains acteurs du sport
professionnel ont tendance à oublier
quelque peu leur rôle social et éducatif
et où le monde associatif et ses
bénévoles sont montrés du doigt je pense
bien évidemment à la réforme de la
gouvernance de la fédération française
de football
le scandaleux clients traversy pourtant
rien ne prouve qu'une gestion par des
professionnels nous aurait épargné des
épices épisode que nous avons traversée
depuis la dernière coupe du monde de
football certains autres rapporteurs a
rejeté notre amendement en commission
considérant qu'il était sans portée
normative
mais si l'avant si nous l'avons
redéposer c'est pour obtenir la garantie
madame la ministre que ce principe
figurera bien au contenu des charges d
éthique fixé réglementairement madame la
ministre vous vous êtes engagés en ce
sens en matière de respect du
développement durable
pouvons nous compter sur vous de la même
manière sur le principe d'unité du
mouvement sportif
je vous remercie claude mais elle
monsieur le rapporteur quelle est
l'opinion de la commission ce président
madame le ministre
le lien puissant entre le sport amateur
et le sport professionnel est démontrée
par de très nombreuses dispositions du
code du sport
cet amendement a visé essentiellement
déclaratives n'apporterait donc rien au
droit existant c'est pourquoi je rends
un avis défavorable
madame la ministre oui monsieur le
sénateur comme vous l'a révélé rappelait
d'ailleurs beaucoup de dispositions du
code du sport ont trait à l'unité du
sport aux principes d'unité du sport
vise à le défendre et d'ailleurs
récemment lors des états généraux du
football
ce principe a été réaffirmé donc je
voudrais vraiment vous rassurer oui nous
allons reprendre ce principe au sein des
dispositions du décret qui vise à
déterminer les items nécessaire de ses
futurs charte éthique c'est un principe
fondamental au sein du sport français
auquel d'ailleurs le comité national
olympique et sportif français est
extrêmement attaché
donc je veux vous rassurer sur ce point
et vous inviter à retirer votre
amendement alors nous avons un avis
défavorable du rapporteur une demande de
retrait de
l'âme la ministre claude mais elle
madame la ministre c'est bien parce que
vous nous avez rassuré et que nous le
maintenant il est maintenu y at il des
demandes d'explications de vote qui est
pour adopter cet amendement qui et
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté et l'article 1er en l'état qui
est pour l'adopter y at il une demande
de parole qui est pour l'adopter qui est
contre qui s'abstient le groupe crc spg
ou socialiste bien il est adopté
l'article 1er l'article 2 je le rappelle
est supprimé nous en arrivons à l'examen
de l'article 3 et c'est notre collègue
jean jacques lozach qui nous présente
l'amendement numéro 9
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre
en ce qui concerne cet article 3 la
mesure de plafonnement salariale
applicables au club est une des mesures
les plus innovantes et sans doute les
plus originales de la proposition de loi
de notre collègue yvon collin dans sa
version initiale ces deux mesures
relevées d'une obligation si nous sommes
favorables à ce que la fixation de ce
plafond soit dévolue aux fédérations
nous regrettons que l'instauration de ce
plafond ne soit plus qu'une possibilité
offerte à ces mêmes fédération car nous
prenons ainsi le risque que certaines
disciplines voire même celles pour
lesquelles il s'avère le plus nécessaire
reste à l'écart de ce mouvement de
modération de la masse salariale de leur
club
ainsi tout le monde s'accorde à dire que
le football français mais aussi
européens vit au dessus de ses moyens
pour deux minables 2010 les pertes
cumulées pour les lits les ligues 1 et 2
atteignent 130 millions d'euros
quatorze clubs de ligue 1 sur 20 ont
enregistré des pertes
le football est pris dans un engrenage
qui atteint ses limites
l'explosion des droits télévisuels sur
ces dernières décennies a nourri la
fuite en avant des salaires des stars du
football et des montants des transferts
la dncg relevé que je cite les recettes
sur mutations sont rendus aléatoires par
un marché des transferts de plus en plus
difficile entraînant un écart important
entre l'estimé et le réel
il revient aux pouvoirs publics de
lutter contre les dérives d'un système à
bout de souffle il me semble ainsi que
cette mesure peut aussi se concevoir
comme un signal fort de soutien aux
règles de fair play financier vers
lesquels s'oriente l'uefa c'est bon
quand nous vous proposons que cette
mesure de plafonnement redevienne une
obligation
merci si monsieur le rapporteur ce
président madame le ministre
cet amendement qui a pour objet
d'obliger les fédérations a fixé un
quota de joueurs formés localement et un
plafond salarial dans les clubs
professionnels est un peu contraire à ce
que nous avons voulu dire jusqu'à
maintenant et
quant à moi qu'il faut laisser à chaque
discipline et à chaque fédération le
soin de définir les conditions
permettant d'assurer la meilleure équité
sportive et que ces conditions peuvent
être différents selon chaque sport par
ailleurs il leur serait extrêmement aisé
de 6,1 montant si élevé il serait
inapplicable
ils ne servent donc à rien de forcer la
main des fédérations il faut au
contraire les responsabilités et leur
faire confiance seront donc un avis
défavorable
madame la ministre même avis monsieur le
président j'en profite pour vous dire
que gaël monfils a gagné c'est une bonne
nouvelle bien excellente les
connaisseurs disent allez alors nous
avons deux avis défavorables sur
l'amendement qui a été présentée par
jean jacques lozach donc qui est pour
l'adopter cet amendement à vous avez
explications de vote vous avez la parole
excusez moi oui je reprend la parole
parce que je je rappelle je dirais
l'important c'est l'originalité de ce
dispositif qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui et je sais de m'attarder
plus particulièrement sur les
dispositions retirait de l'ancien
article 5 est ajoutée à la fin de cet
article 3 les règlements d'accès aux
compétitions des fédérations pourront
dorénavant déterminer outre le nombre de
sportifs formés localement le fameux
salary cap c'est à dire comme
l'expliquent le texte de la proposition
de loi
le montant maximal relatifs aux absolu
de la somme des rémunérations versées
aux sportifs par chaque société ou
associations sportives la précision des
termes est essentielle là où le texte
originel prévoyait une obligation de
limitation des rémunérations
la ppl tel qu issu des travaux de la
commission dit bien que les règlements
peuvent contenir des dispositions sur ce
point on peut craindre alors que les
fédérations ne prennent pas le risque
d'instaurer un salary cap souvent très
impopulaire parmi leurs dirigeants ce
qui je crois va limiter considérablement
la portée de cette proposition de loi
il existe je l'admets plusieurs limites
à ce système on peut craindre c'est vrai
un développement des rémunérations non
déclarés
qui échapperaient donc au salary cap
mais aussi à tout impôt nous avons
cependant france un dispositif de
contrôle de gestion presque unique en
europe
et si leurs moyens de leur permettent
j'espère que ses services serait le cas
échéant mesure de déceler des
comportements de ce type on murray
encore a également que si les sportifs
professionnels voient leurs salaires
limitent à la hausse
ils risquent de céder aux sirènes des
championnats étrangers jean reviendra
lors l'argumentation que j'avais
développé dans mon intervention du
discussion générale
c'est précisément à cause de ce biais
qu'il faut convaincre nos partenaires
européens d'aller vers une harmonisation
économique et fiscale dans le domaine du
sport
l'action de michel platini et dans ce
domaine tout à fait exemplaire au sein
de l'uefa
il faut mettre fin aux dérives encouragé
par les plus grands clubs de football du
monde
bastian dru doctorant à l'université
paris ouest nanterre la défense
rappelait récemment que les salaires des
joueurs de football représente est
parfois plus de 100 % des revenus des
clubs situation parfaitement ubuesque
l'endettement cumulé des clubs européens
représentent aujourd'hui près de 15
milliards d'euros dont presque un
milliard pour le seul club de manchester
united qui disputait ce week-end la
finale de la ligue des champions
l'endettement de manchester et du real
madrid ne leur permettraient pas
d'évoluer en championnat professionnel
de france dncg prononcerait purement et
simplement leur rétrogradation
administrative créée un salary cap
obligatoire c'est faire preuve d'une
volonté de mettre fin à l' endettement
structurel des clubs professionnels de
football
essentiellement le faire les châles
européenne c'est aussi mettre des clubs
sur un pied d'égalité
le championnat de top 14 de rugby a bien
mis en place ce type de système en
france ainsi que la division 2 italienne
de football
semble-t-il avec succès inspirons nous
de cette initiative
ayons le courage moraliser le sport en
résumé nous semble possible de concilier
excellence des résultats et salaires
raisonnables des sportifs concernés
ne sommes nous pas champion du monde et
champion olympique de handball avec un
salaire moyen mensuel de 4500 euros dans
le championnat national de première
division
notre souci est donc d'accroître le
pouvoir de régulation des fédérations à
elle de fixer le seuil au final de la
masse salariale au sein du budget du
club
bien sûr ce niveau ne saurait est
identique pour les différents sports
nous rejoignant ainsi le souci du fair
play financier
plusieurs fois rappelé par les collègues
dans cette enceinte nous recherchons une
exigence de transparence d'équité
sportive et financière
le risque des rémunérations dont des
cars est bien réelle ne doit pas nous
tétaniser nous paralyser et nous
empêcher d'aller de l'avant
le risque est réel celui de la bulle
financière appliquée à certains sports
professionnels
par manque de vigilance d'anticipation à
des régulations
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
regrette que l'obligation ne soit pas
retenue
merci madame la ministre juste un petit
mot de précisions nous partageons les
objectifs de votre amendement simplement
vous avez évoqué effectivement la
dimension européenne il faut savoir qu'à
l'initiative de la france
la dernière résolution qui a été adoptée
en conseil des ministres européens sur
le plan d'action européen dans le
domaine du sport prévoit bien un travail
à l'échelle européenne sur ces
différents sujets et notamment sur le
salary cap
merci alors je rappelle sur l'amendement
de jean jacques lozach deux avis
défavorables qui est pour adopter cet
amendement 4 qui est contre 5
il n'est pas adoptée est par contre je
soumets à votre approbation l'article 3
qui est pour l'adopter qui est contre
il est adopté je rappelle que l'article
4 et supprimer l'article 5 reste en
l'état
l'article si ce n'est pas modifié et
nous en arrivons à l'examen de l'article
6 bis notamment par l'examen de
l'amendement numéro 3 que nous présente
jean françois voguet qui est l
amendement de suppression des sept
articles à l'origine introduit dans la
loppsi 2 refait surface
ce malgré son invalidation par le
conseil constitutionnel il prévoit de
sanctionner en tant que telle la revente
illicite de titres d'accès à une
manifestation sportive
on ne comprend pas en quoi cette
incrimination spécifique permettrait de
mieux assurer la protection de l'ordre
public alors qu'ils existent déjà par
ailleurs des solutions pénale pour
atteinte à l'ordre public
de même pour la vente et la revente
illégale nous ne sommes pas en présence
d'une zone de non droit et introduire la
possibilité de sanctions de 15 sont de
15000 euros par non d'amande paraît donc
inutile conseil constitutionnel dans sa
décision du 10 mars 2011 a censuré cet
article qui me connaît le principe de
nécessité des délits et des peines
malgré les petites modifications opérées
sur cette pratique
cette critique continuera de s'appliquer
et donc nous souhaitons la suppression
de cet article
merci jean françois voguet nous seuls
rapporteur ce président madame la
ministre
la revente illicite de billets qu'elle
se fasse aux abords des stades ou sur
internet créé de nombreux problèmes
les spectateurs supporters d'une équipe
se retrouve au milieu des supporters de
l'autre équipe avec les conséquences que
l'on connaît
d'autres se voir refouler à l'entrée des
stades
lorsqu'ils détiennent des faux billets
ce qui provoque des risques des bagarres
des affrontements enfin les
organisateurs font face aux plaintes des
supporters qui achètent leurs billets à
des prix extrêmement élevés parce que
les revendeurs pratique une spéculation
néfaste à l'image du sport
ce nouveau délit devrait permettre de
faciliter le combat contre le trafic de
billets seront donc un avis défavorable
même la ministre merci monsieur le
président comme monsieur le rapporteur
vient de le rappeler le code pénal ne
prévoit pas actuellement des
dispositions adéquates pour lutter
efficacement contre la revente illicite
de billets sans l'accord des
organisateurs
et vous savez combien ça peut être
créateur de troubles à l'ordre public et
générateur d'une économie souterraine
donc le nouveau dispositif
qu'il est prévu dans la proposition de
loi intègre bien d'ailleurs les
observations du conseil constitutionnel
qui avait entraîné
l'inconstitutionnalité des dispositions
de la loppsi à deux titres la première
c'est que il l'est bien ciblée sur les
manifestations sportives dont il n'a pas
un chant aussi large que là que le
prévoyait la loppsi et d'autre part il
ne vise que la fin ils visent la revente
sur tout type de support et et pas
uniquement internet donc ces
dispositions nous semble mieux mieux
calibrée pour autant il ya encore
quelques interrogations au sein du
ministère de la justice sur sa
constitutionnalité
donc nous nous en remettons à la sagesse
de votre haute assemblée alors nous
avons un avis défavorable de la
commission sagesse de madame la ministre
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote qui est pour adopter cet amendement
qui est contre il n'est pas adoptée est
par contre l'article 6 bis qui est pour
adopter l'article 6 bis et contre qui
s'abstient l'article 6 bis est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'examen donc de
l'article 6 ter et c'est christian
cointat qui nous présente l'amendement
de rectifier mais monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
cet article permet aux fédérations de
fixer la rémunération des avocats
intervenant en tant que mandataire de
sportifs et ainsi il propose de revenir
sur l'article 10 de la loi du 31
décembre 76 tel que modifié par le
parlement le 22 décembre dernier qui
ouvrait aux avocats l'activité de
mandataire sportif ses propositions de
réforme je le souligne étaient
préconisées dans le rapport que de la
commission darrois a remis au président
de la république
il ya donc une certaine incohérence dans
la proche qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui puisque deux mois après on
veut modifier le dispositif tel qu'il
avait été adopté tant par le cénacle par
l'assemblée nationale
je précise aussi que la sécurité g
juridique des conventions ne pouvait
qu'être renforcée par l'intervention
d'un avocat
donc qui est un spécialiste du conseil
juridique et des contrats il intervient
dans un cadre déontologique parfaitement
connus avec des principes d'indépendance
et d'interdiction du conflit d'intérêts
son intervention dans le domaine sportif
est donc de nature à protéger les
sportifs et les clubs l'exercice cette
activité par les avocats supposé
toutefois d'être adapté à leur statut
en effet toute activité commerciale hors
est interdite sur une activité en
qualité de mandataire et nom d'agent
sportif leur a été permise le statut
d'agent sportif et notamment
l'obligation d'avoir une licence et
d'être soumis à discipline des
fédérations sportives est contraire aux
principes essentiels de la profession
vouloir imposer la fixation des
honoraires par les fédérations sportives
revient à remettre en cause le principe
de la fixation libre d'honoraires entre
l'avocat et son client en cas de
contestation sur leur montant une
procédure de contestation devant le
bâtonnier avec appel devant le premier
président de la cour d'appel est
organisée le dispositif retenu par le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale
il y a quelques mois d'avocats
mandataire sportif apparaît donc comme
parfaitement équilibrées en ce qui
concerne en ce qu'il conserve ses
principes tout en garantissant la
moralisation du sport par la soumission
des avocats la limitation de la
rémunération à 10% du montant du contrat
conclu avec le club et à l'obligation de
transmission de tous les contrats aux
fédérations sportives
si la fédération détecte un abus elle
doit en informer le bâtonnier qui dit
j'entre à les poursuites disciplinaires
par ailleurs l'avocat est soumis aux
mêmes sanctions pénales que celles
applicables aux agents sportifs en vertu
du code du sport
c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'amendement qui vous est présentée
propose la suppression de l'article 6
ter pour revenir au texte qui a été voté
il ya environ deux mois par le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale
merci monsieur le rapporte le texte est
voté il ya deux mois c'est à dire cinq
mois après un autre texte qui prévoyait
autre chose mais un petit point de
détail que je
relève au passage je me tiendrai
simplement ce qu'a décidé la commission
de la culture
l'amendement qui nous est soumis et est
contraire à la position de notre
commission et je rends donc vous se
prendra pas un avis défavorable à mme la
ministre
merci monsieur le président le
gouvernement lui est très favorable aux
dispositions de l'article 6 ter en ce
qu'il permet de limiter l'inflation des
commissions d'agent et vous savez qu'il
est même dans la ligne 2 des réflexions
actuelles de la fifa puisque la fifa
prépare un texte qui prévoit un
plafonnement de la rémunération des
agents sportifs à 3%
donc nous sommes même au delà de ces
fameux 3% et simplement pour citer
quelques chiffres sur cette inflation du
montant des commissions de transfert et
des commissions des agents
les récentes études européennes sur
l'échelle de ces rémunérations donne
quelques chiffres pour le football
l'échelle des revenus annuels de d'agent
sportif va par exemple de 13000 à trois
millions sept en europe
en montant annuel dans le handball dans
le rugby par dont elles vont de 15000 à
585 milles euros annuels donc vous voyez
qu'il ya lieu de légiférer sur ce sur ce
point le premier point que je voudrais
indiquer à monsieur le sénateur c'est
qu' il serait inefficace de limiter les
seules rémunérations des agents sportifs
aux agents qui ne sont pas avocat je
crains d'ailleurs que ça n'entraîne une
véritable rupture de l'égalité
concurrentiel qui soient jugées
illégales
deuxième point cette disposition cet
article 6 ter ne remet pas en cause
l'article 10 de la loi de 1971 portant
réforme de certaines professions
judiciaires et juridiques loi qui avait
été arctique qui a été récemment
modifiée comme vous l'avez rappelé par
la loi du 28 mars 2011
en effet cet article distraite des
rémunérations des avocats et a notamment
aligner les contraintes de rémunération
des avocats mandataires de sportifs sur
scène
des agents sportifs enfin je pense
important de préciser un point c'est que
le plafonnement des commissions se fera
bien discipline par discipline et non
contrat par contrat
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'y mets
un avis défavorable à cet amendement
alors nous avons deux avis défavorable
sur cet amendement y at il des demandes
d'explication de votre qui est pour
l'adopter
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté et l'article 6 ter en l'état
qui est pour l'adopter l'article sister
explications de vote jean jacques lozach
président quelques mois après l'adoption
la proposition de loi vise à encadrer la
profession d'agent sportif voilà déjà
que l'on reprend que l'on retoque
certaines de ses dispositions
l'article 6 ter du texte qui nous est
soumis aujourd'hui permet en effet aux
fédérations délégataires de fixer dans
le cadre de la rémunération des agents
sportifs un montant inférieur à 10% du
contrat conclu par les partis mise en
rapport
je ne peux qu'approuver cette évolution
jeu permettrait également de rappeler
que dans ce même hémicycle mes collègues
du groupe socialiste avions averti voici
au nom du gouvernement et la majorité
des dangers de ce texte
comme bien souvent on avait les alors
légiférer dans l'urgence pour satisfaire
quelques intérêts à la proche de la
coupe du monde de football j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire à plusieurs reprises
une politique sportive à courte vue est
condamné à être réadapté et amendé en
permanence
tout se passe comme si nous avancions
par un coup en tâtonnant dans le
brouillard puis cerise on s'éclaircir
les pouvoirs publics trouver enfin un
cap à tenir la loi encadrant leur
profession d'agent sportif était donc de
ce point de vue tout à fait
symptomatique d orientation ou plutôt de
l'absence d'orientation du ministère
elle est également tout à fait
caractéristique de la vision du sport
qui transparaît souvent dans les textes
portés par le gouvernement à savoir une
ambition première concernant l'argent et
le profit
c'était aussi un texte de dérogation
puisqu'on n'avait pas su empêcher le
paiement des agents sportifs par les
clubs
alors il suffisait de le légaliser
c'était le noeud central du texte de loi
sur les agents sportifs
et que dire de l'autorisation et c'est
l'objet de la bande m'en donner aux
avocats quelques mois plus tard de
pratiquer l'activité d'agent sportif
s'il ne faut pas blâmer tous les agents
sportifs force est de constater que
notamment dans le football
ils font partie des acteurs qui d'une
certaine façon pousse au crime entre
guillemets l'inflation des transferts de
joueurs est à leur avantage et il pousse
en ce sens je rappellerai que frédéric
thiriez président de la ligue nationale
de football avait déclaré devant le
député dominique juillot je cite
globalement le football français est un
milieu relativement propre sauf
précisément dans un domaine celui des
transferts
la liberté laissée aux agents y est pour
beaucoup le sport a besoin de davantage
d'éthique notamment dans les transferts
et la proposition de mode mes collègues
du groupe rdse est donc la bienvenue en
la matière ceci dit je rappelle que
comme nous avions voté contre le texte
relative aux agents sportifs
vous comprendrez bien que ici
aujourd'hui par rapport à cet amendement
sur le même objet de nous abstiendrons
bien alors nous en sommes à l'adoption
de l'article 6 ter qui est pour
l'adopter quai pour qui et contre
observer et abstention du groupe
socialiste
merci je n'ai rien sur l'article 6
quater qui est adopté en l'état il en
est de même pour l'article 6 qu'inquiets
ce et nous en arrivons à l'article 6 ex
yes et madame la ministre nous présente
l'amendement numéro 18
merci monsieur le président conformément
à l'engagement que nous avions pris en
commission nous vous proposons une
nouvelle réaction de l'amendement qui
était propose présenté par votre collège
ambroise dupont
cet amendement cette disposition vise à
créer un délit pénal de corruption
sportive liée aux manifestations
sportives qui font l'objet de paris
c'était un engagement que nous avions
pris à la suite du rapport de
jean-françois vilotte président de
l'arjel sur la prévention de la
option et c'est aussi une recommandation
faite par le rapport des députés
jean-françois lamour et aurélie
filippetti en même nom par mai 2010
d'ailleurs très récemment
je n'ai pas la date de ce jeu n'est pas
la date de ce rapport alors pourquoi
créer un délit de corruption sportive
sur le fond les instruments juridiques
que nous avons aujourd'hui sont
largement insuffisant puisque sur le
plan pénal la définition actuelle des
infractions de corruption public ou
privé ne permettent pas de couvrir
l'ensemble des cas possibles de
corruption dans le cadre sportif et les
procédures disciplinaires qui peuvent
être menées par les fédérations
sportives ne permettent pas non plus une
réponse adéquate face à ses cadres pour
corruption
c'est la raison pour laquelle lyon
françois vilotte s'est inspiré des
dispositions qui existent dans d'autres
pays je pense notamment au royaume uni à
l'espagne ou à l'italie qui ont créé un
délit de corruption sportive aussi bien
pour le corrupteur que pour le corrompu
ce qui facilitera la mise en oeuvre de
moyens d'investigation et bien
évidemment qui aura un effet dissuasif
extrêmement fort donc pourquoi
avons-nous souhaité réécrire le texte
adopté en commission
d'une part parce que le texte qui était
proposée initialement était directement
lié au code du sport et le ministère de
la justice propose de rattacher le délit
de corruption sportive à deux délits
pénaux existants la corruption privée
active et la corruption privée passive
ce qui permettra d'assurer une sécurité
juridique maximum et une meilleure
lisibilité du dispositif est donc ce qui
facilitera le travail des services
répressifs et de la et de la justice
d'autre part la limitation de se dédier
à la corruption en lien avec les paris
sportifs permet parfaitement de
justifier la création de ce délit au
regard du principe de nécessité des
peines qui aurait pu être également un
motif d'inconstitutionnalité
voilà la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons cette nouvelle écriture et je
tiens tout particulièrement à la
création de ce délit de corruption
je vous remercie un monsieur le
rapporteur jean françois humbert
ce président malam ministre cet
amendement que vous ne nous présenter
n'apporte que des modifications
marginales au dispositif introduit par
la commission je rends donc un avis
favorable
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote après l'avis favorable
jean jacques lozach oui tout à l'heure
effectivement je disais que je notre
président serait une position
d'abstention par rapport aux articles
inhérents aussi bien aux paris sportifs
qu'aux agents sportifs mais je dois dire
que la nature et la force même de la
création de ce délit de corruption
sportive appliquer effectivement au pari
nous amène à déroger si je peux dire la
position exprimée tout à l'heure et donc
nous votre eau contre madame la ministre
cet amendement pour allah je me reprends
excusez moi nous voterons pour votre
amende non madame la ministre
voilà là tout le monde comprend alors en
fait cet article cet amendement réécrit
l'article 6 ex y est ce donc qui est
pour adopter l'amendement gouvernemental
eh bien il est adopté à l'unanimité des
présents et l'article 6 ex s est ainsi
adopté et nous abordons le titre 2 qui a
trait au développement du score et là
nous avons une petite rectification
puisque nous avons un amendement un
amendement 24 rectifié qui vise inséré
un article additionnel avant l'article 7
ha et c'est le rapporteur qui nous
présente
monsieur le président madame la ministre
la loi du 16 juillet 1984 à imposer aux
clubs sportifs évoluant dans les ligues
professionnelles et disposant de
ressources financières substantielles de
se constituer sous la forme d'une
structure très original l'association
personnalité morale représentant le club
conserve la gestion de la pratique
amateur mais doit créer une société
commerciale spécifique en charge de la
section professionnelle
notre commission tient d'emblée à
souligner qu'elle est attachée à cette
structuration qui marque le lien entre
le monde amateur et le monde
professionnel et à la convention qui lie
le club à l'association support le
moment que je vous présente vise
uniquement à prévoir que les clubs
peuvent sortir du carcan laisse ta tante
des statuts types qui complexifie le
droit qui leur est applicable qui n'ont
pas été revues depuis un certain temps
et dont l'utilité n'a jamais été
démontrée cela ne remet en cause ni les
conventions ni l'attribution du numéro
d'affiliation ni la limitation de la
multipropriété ni la limitation des
prêts et consciemment sportif ni
l'interdiction de bénéficier de
certaines aides ni l'interdiction de se
voir accorder des garanties d'emprunt
par les collectivités territoriales ni
enfin l'encadrement de l'appel public à
l'épargné
la société sportive ne sera donc pas une
société de droit commun loin s'en faut
mais le droit qui lui sera applicable
sera clarifiée si madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président
évidemment la question du statut des
sociétés sportives est une question
importante voire primordiale parce que
derrière ce statut c'est un peu la
philosophie les principes que nous avons
du sport et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il est difficile il même
impossible en tout cas enfin pour moi il
est difficile d'assimiler le sport à une
entreprise événementiel ou une
entreprise de spectacle
la proposition qui est faite a le défaut
de compliquer la situation puisque nous
pourrions avoir s'ils statut pour les
sociétés sportives qui coexistent si
statut différent puisque nous rajoute
aurions aux statuts existants
les statuts des des sociétés de droit
commun sans deuxième défaut c'est que
elle ne prévoit pas toutes les
dispositions qui permettent d'encadrer
le sport et notamment par exemple ne
règle pas la question du commissaire aux
comptes puisque vous savez que dans les
sarl et les sas le principe du
commissaire aux comptes n'est pas
obligatoire par conséquent ils ne sont
qu'une évolution aussi radicale
exigerait préalablement un travail
notamment un travail au sein d'un groupe
qui puisse en identifier tous les
tenants et tous les aboutissants c'est
la raison pour laquelle gouvernement
vous invite à retirer cet amendement
à défaut nous aimerions un avis
défavorable alors monsieur le rapporteur
vous savez monsieur le président il a
été déposée après mûre réflexion donc
nous le maintenons en 24 rectifié est
maintenue je rappelle c'est l'amendement
de la commission avec une demande de
retrait qui vient d'être refusée donc
c'est un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour adopter cet
amendement 24 rectifié qu'est peau
alors 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 qui est contre 3
voilà donc il est adopté il est adopté
et l'article additionnel avant l'article
7 à bien nous poursuivons alors le
l'amendement numéro 10 puisque nous
abordons l'article 7 1
c'est jean jacques lozach qui nous le
présente cet amendement nous l'avons
conçu comme un amant demande de
précaution en commission le rapporteur a
fait part de sa volonté de modifier les
statuts des sociétés sportives par le
dépôt d'un amendement en séance hors
statut des sociétés multipropriété multi
financement sont des questions
intimement liée pour apprécier
l'organisation et l'économie du sport
professionnel sans connaissance du
contenu de la portée des modifications
envisagées par le rapporteur
nous avons jugé prudent de déposer un
amendement de suppression de cet article
introduit en commission
autant nous souscrivons dispositif de
l'article 6 de renforcement des règles
d'incompatibilité applicable en matière
de contrôle de sociétés sportives
parce qu'il est temps à la notion d'
influence notable autant de sommes plus
circonspect sur l'assouplissement des
prêts et cautionnement entre clubs
si la doctrine juge le régime
d'interdiction du multi financement des
clubs archaïque
celui ci n'a jamais été évoqué
spontanément par les acteurs du sport
professionnel que nous avons auditionné
tous en revanche on insisté sans
exception sur la formation
j'ai bien noté l'argument de notre
rapporteur selon lequel une banque
détenant une part mais minime de
sociétés sportives ne peut plus financer
un autre club de la même discipline
mais j'estime à tout le moins que cet
assouplissement mérite une plus amples
discussions
jean françois humbert quel est votre
avis sur cet amendement de suppression
ce président tableau istres cet
amendement est contraire
la position de notre commission qui
estime qu'il faut rapport renforcer la
capacité des établissements bancaires à
prêter de l'argent au club
c'est pourquoi je rendrai un avis
défavorable j'ajouterai qu'il faut
savoir qu'une banque qui détient
aujourd'hui 20% du d'un club comme c'est
le cas dans un club mythique du nord de
la france il ne s'agit pas de lille ne
peut pas exercer son métier auprès d'un
autre club à cause des dispositions
actuelles même un ministre avis
défavorable deux avis défavorables sur
l'amendement numéro 10 de jean jacques
lozach
y at il des demandes de parole qui est
pour adopter cet amendement numéro 10 3
qui est contre quatre qui est contre il
n'est pas adopté et l'article 7 ha en
l'état qui est pour l'adopter
qui est contre il est adopté nous en
arrivons à au titre 2 qui concerne la
formation et des droits des sportifs
l'article 7 est adopté en l'état il
n'est pas modifié il en est de même pour
l'article 8 qui est adopté en l'état et
nous en arrivons à l'article 8 bis et
c'est toujours madame la ministre qui
nous présente l'amendement numéro 21
merci monsieur le président nous vous
proposons donc un amendement de
suppression de cet article pour les
raisons suivantes vous savez que la taxe
d'apprentissage est divisé en deux
parties une partie quotas qui
représentent 52 % de son montant et qui
financent exclusivement l'apprentissage
est une partie barème 48% et qui finance
tout les premières formations
technologiques ou professionnelles
l'article 8 bis tel qu'il est rédigé
autorise les entreprises à verser leurs
taxes pour la part barème aux centres de
formation des clubs sportifs et je
voudrais juste attirer votre attention
sur les conséquences que pourraient
avoir ces dispositions les entreprises
qui donnerait aux centres de formation
des clubs de football parce que
contrairement
traitement en fait c'est de ça dont il
s'agit qui donnerait cet agent donc
d'argent au centre de formation ne le
donnerai plus au cfa ou au lycée
professionnel ce qui pourrait avoir
évidemment des conséquences importantes
pour cette structure puisque vous savez
qu'il faut grosso modo trois mille euros
pour former un apprenti dans une chambre
de dans une chambre de métiers ensuite
le il faut savoir que le ministère de
l'emploi conduit actuellement un
dialogue constructif avec l'union des
clubs professionnels de football qui
vise justement à aider les jeunes qui
sortent des centres de formation sont
êtres avoir de contrat professionnel et
qui donc sortent sans rien enfin presque
sans rien c'est ça le vrai sujet
aujourd'hui il y a grosso modo un joueur
sur dix qui finit ans qui sort de centre
de formation avec un contrat
professionnel de football
ça veut dire qu'il en reste neuf qui
doivent trouver un autre métier
c'est sur ce point que travaille
actuellement le ministère de l'emploi
avec l'union des clubs professionnels de
football
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons de supprimer cet article
alors monsieur le rapporteur
quelle est votre opinion sur cet
amendement gouvernemental
monsieur le président cet amendement qui
est contraire à la position de la
commission laissées f1 bénéficie de la
part quotas et hors quota de la taxe
d'apprentissage
l'objet du dispositif introduit par la
commission et donc pas de mettre en
concurrence les cfa et les centres de
formation agréé par le ministère des
sports mais de permettre à ces derniers
de collecter une part minoritaire de la
taxe d'apprentissage se lavera cela
devrait desserrer un peu là contraintes
pesant sur les collectivités sur
lesquels prennent pèse principalement
aujourd'hui le financement des centres
de formation donc un avis défavorable et
par ailleurs le dispositif de la
commission concerne tous les sports et
pas seulement le football et surtout
permettre à donner une réalité à
l'obligation de jouer avec des
sportifs formés localement c'est une des
dispositions présente dans la
proposition de loi de notre collègue et
de ses amis alors y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
alors je rappelle les positions il
s'agit d'un amendement gouvernemental
mais le rapporteur donne un avis
défavorable qui est pour adopter
l'amendement gouvernemental 3 4 5 qui
est contre 4 donc l'amendement est
adopté et l'article et 8 bis est
supprimé alors nous passons à l'examen
du titre iii protection de la santé des
sportifs et lutte contre le dopage
un titre important alors le chapitre
premier monsieur le rapporteur
c'est un amendement coordination
effectivement d'abonnement encore dix
ans on est d'accord même la ministre
oui et d'autres assemblées d'accord pour
cet abondement de coordination
oui donc le chapitre premier est adopté
en l'état sur l'article 9
je ne suis saisi d'aucun amendements et
d'aucune demande de parole je mets aux
voix cet article qui est pour l'adopter
allez il est adopté sur les articles 10
à 24 je suis saisi également d' aucun
amendement et d'aucune demande de parole
puis-je considérer que le vote est le
même et que ces articles sont adoptés et
que la suppression est maintenu ou selon
le cas la suppression maintenu bon c'est
la même position c'est le même vote bien
je vous remercie
et nous en sommes arrivés par ce biais
là à l'article 27 25 par dont quatre
amendements identiques qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune
ce sont des amendements de suppression
et je donne la parole à jean françois
voguet pour nous présenter
l'amendement numéro 4 oui monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président madame
ministre chers collègues cet article en
effet transfert l'intégralité des
pouvoirs de sanction en matière de
dopage a la chance française de lutte
contre le dopage
elle savait déjà mais essentiellement en
deuxième instance la première instance
étant assuré par les fédérations nous
considérons que cet article ouvre la
voie à une véritable
déresponsabilisation des fédérations en
matière de dopage
ce qui ne nous semble pas souhaitable en
outre ce faisant on avait fait le d
détiendrait le pouvoir de prévention
d'enquêtés et de sanctions en matière de
dopage
ce mode de paul et se mélangent des
pouvoirs nous pose évidemment problème
de plus chacun sait qu'actuellement la
fée le dé est déjà en sous financement
pour ces missions alors lui rajouter
d'autres prérogatives sans prévoir de
budget complémentaire ne nous semble pas
très réaliste
en effet cette agence peine déjà à
accomplir les missions qui lui sont
confiées en matière de dopage au sein de
ces départements de contrôle et
d'analysé on peut donc légitimement se
demander comment elle pourrait mener à
bien cette nouvelle mission
elle a de plus en plus souvent recours
aux services de l'état en région pour
des contrôles que l' agence assumer
auparavant par elle-même et son
département d'un ali semble est en
rupture de matériel face à la pénurie de
moyens financiers humains ils ne nous
sont pas souhaitables d'étendre ses
compétences au lieu de supprimer le
pouvoir de sanction des fédérations il
ne serait préférable donné tous les
mules tout est moyen de l'assumer et de
renforcer les fédérations dans ce
domaine en leur donnant les moyens de se
développer en leur sein la prévention et
la lutte contre le dopage et de mener à
bien des missions d'éducation de suivi
médical des sportifs qui sont de leurs
compétences voilà l'objet de notre
abonnement de suppression
merci bien c'est claude domeizel qui
nous présente le train
merci monsieur le président madame amis
sont mes chers collègues beaucoup
d'arguments déjà été apporté au débat
concernant la dévolution du pouvoir de
sanction en première instance mais l'un
d'entre eux me semble primer ôter tout
pouvoir de sanction aux fédérations
sportives en matière de dopage participe
d'une déresponsabilisation de ses
structures dans la lutte contre le
dopage qui ne sera pas sans conséquence
un autre sur leurs missions de
prévention
c'est une vision largement partagé sur
nos bancs il me semble de même que par
les acteurs sportifs
par ailleurs si les fédérations de très
petite taille n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de traiter les affaires de dopage
la fld a compétence pour intervenir en
cas de carence de six fédérations
il en est de même lorsque nos
fédérations se refuserait pour une
question d'image à prendre des sanctions
disciplinaires contre l'un des sportifs
d'ailleurs si l'on se réfère aux
statistiques relatives aux saisines de
la fld en 2009 et bien en 2009 les
carences des fédérations ne représente
que 12% des décisions de solutions de
lagence enfin concernant le traitement
différencié d'affaires similaires par la
fédération
la compétence de la fld pour réformer
les décisions prises par les fédérations
à gré est un facteur dom au génie de
l'homogénéisation des sanctions est donc
un gage d'équité entre les sportifs les
décisions de réformation représente à
cet égard la majorité des décisions de
sanction de l'agencé pourquoi il est
proposé par cet amendement de revenir au
dispositif existant de partage équilibré
du pouvoir de sanction disciplinaire
entre les fédérations et l' agence
française de lutte contre le dopage tout
en intégrant la création de la
commission des sanctions haute celle de
cette agence je vous remercie
merci claude donzel et puis nous allons
goûter notre plaisir jusqu'au bout
puisque même le gouvernement dépose un
amendement de suppression
et après monsieur le rapporteur merci
monsieur le président pour ne pas vous
décevoir
effectivement je nous avons déposé un
amendement de suppression qui est fondée
sur deux raisons principales la première
c'est que actuellement l' agence
française de lutte contre le dopage a
déjà juridiquement tous les moyens pour
se saisir des cas qui ne seraient pas
sanctionnés dans les délais impartis par
les fédérations si on constate un cas de
dopage et que la fédération ne prend pas
la décision dans le délai requis qui est
en moyenne de 10 semaines la fld peut
s'auto saisir du cas est sanctionné
elle-même le sportif incriminés d'autre
part si la fld considère que la
fédération après une sanction
insuffisante au regard de l'infraction
elle peut aller au delà et demandé une
peine une peine supplémentaire et
d'ailleurs elle l'a fait à plusieurs
reprises puisque en 2010 sur 286
infractions constatées par la fld à 148
reprises l'agencé a été saisie ou a
décidé de se saisir de ces de ces
dossiers
le deuxième élément est que cette
disposition risquerait de
déresponsabiliser les fédérations et
nous avons besoin d'elle notamment pour
la prévention du dopage
vous savez que nous avons adopté des
dispositions qui maintenant oblige les
fédérations adopté un plan de prévention
du dopage sinon elles ne peuvent pas
bénéficier de subventions publiques
notamment de subventions du ministère
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons de supprimer cet article
or mme c'est le rapporteur la vie il
n'est pas besoin de commenter davantage
monsieur le président or quels sont les
avis après que sur ouais en fait tout le
monde est d'accord donc explications de
vote parce que je pourrais très bien
demander l'avis du rapporteur sur
leucate de jean françois voguet d'un
califat bras et puis il en est de même
sur le 13 1 et sur l'amendement du
gouvernement
donc at il des demandes d'explications
de vote sur non tout le monde s'est
exprimé
alors qui est pour supprimer
cet article et oui alors c'est la
majorité qui s'abstient voilà donc cet
amant cet article est supprimé l'article
ensuite nous avons l'amendement 11 qui
est présenté par jean jacques lozach qui
vise inséré un article additionnel après
l'article 25 oui monsieur le président
madame la ministre
l'efficacité de la lutte contre le
dopage nécessite une concertation accrue
de tous ces acteurs en particulier à
l'échelon international
plusieurs dispositions de la proposition
de loi en oeuvre en ce sens je pense à
l'article 15 à la possibilité ouverte à
la fld d'exercer ses missions de
contrôle et analyse lors de la tenue de
manifestations nationales à l'étranger
ou encore la reconnaissance de la
coopération entre la fld les agences
nationales de lutte contre le dopage
étrangères notre abandon s'inscrit dans
la même logique il vise à assurer de
meilleures coopération et concertation
entre la fld et ses homologues à
l'étranger en renforçant leur capacité
d'information il abily ainsi entre la
fld les agences nationales de lutte
contre le dopage étrangères les échanges
de renseignements obtenus dans
l'accomplissement de leurs missions
respectives et relatif aux substances et
procédés dopants à leur emploi et à leur
mise en circulation
la fld s'est déjà rapproché des agences
antidopages allemandes autrichiennes et
suisses avec lesquels sont organisées
des réunions conjointes et des
consultations régulières depuis 2007 la
fld à intégrer le réseau des agences
nationales de lutte contre le dopage
à travers la nadau c'est à dire
l'association des organisations
nationales antidopage
il s'agit donc à travers cet amendement
d'amplifier ce mouvement de coopération
déjà largement engagé en donnant une
base légale aux échanges d'informations
entre l'afd et les autres agences merci
aussi le rapporteur avis favorable
avis favorable madame la ministre nous
avons deux avis favorable sur cet
amendement de jean jacques lozach
y at il des demandes d'explication de
votre qui est pour adopter cet
amendement avis favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement il est
adopté à l'unanimité des présents et
l'article additionnel après l'article 25
y est insérée
nous poursuivons c'est toujours jean
jacques lozach qui nous présente
l'amendement numéro 12 oui c'est un
abonnement je dirais dans le
prolongement dans la continuité du
précédent en effet cet amendement
s'inscrit dans la suite logique de
l'habilitation des échanges
d'informations entre l'afd et les agents
de lutte contre le dopage étrangères et
visent en tirer les conséquences
il autorise ainsi la fld à utiliser les
renseignements obtenus auprès des
agences nationales de lutte contre le
dopage à l'étranger afin que l'agencé
puisse prendre en toute légalité
les cendres sont adéquates contre les
sportifs utilisant les produits dopants
et monsieur le rapporteur l'encore me ce
président à l'avis favorable
même la ministre on suit deux avis
favorables et l'assemblée c'est le même
vote et bien l'art mandement numéro 12
est adopté et l'article additionnel
après l'article 25 est inséré
je n'ai rien sur l'article 26
l'article 27 et supprimer je le rappelle
l'article nous en arrivons à l'article
28 et là c'est claude domeizel qui nous
présente un amendement 14 merci monsieur
le président madame ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement en tirer les
conséquences du maintien du pouvoir de
sanction des fédérations sportives en
matière de dopage
il vise à assurer la coordination en e10
positive relative au dopage animale afin
que nos fédérations sportives puissent
notamment continuer à décider des
sanctions administratives contre le
propriétaire
l'entraîneur où le sportif coupable de
dopage animal jour merci merci monsieur
le rapporteur avis favorable ce
président est bien dit dont on continue
madame la ministre alors deux avis
favorables
notre assemblée adoptent cet amendement
numéro 14 il est adopté et l'article 28
ainsi amende est adoptée dans les mêmes
conditions il est adopté l'article 29 et
réserver jusqu'à la fin du texte
nous attendons un amendement du
gouvernement on est d'accord
alors monsieur le rapporteur vous nous
présentez l'amendement numéro 23
ça va aller très vite c'était le moment
de coordination où le président on est
d'accord madame la ministre et d'autres
assemblées adobe cet amendement de
coordination
il est adopté nous en arrivons à
l'article 30
et c'est le président colin qui nous
présente l'amendement numéro 16 oui
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
l'article 30 a été ajoutée à notre
proposition de loi lors de son examen
par la commission de la culture
hilton a conférée au conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel pouvoir de fixer les
conditions de diffusion
de brefs extraits des compétitions
sportives loin de dénigrer cette
disposition je souhaite sa suppression
pour des raisons de cohérence
j'ai bien conscience de l'intérêt de
cette disposition qui fait défaut à
notre législation
mais comme je l'aï déjà précisé lors des
discussions générales je ne souhaite pas
que notre texte devienne un texte
fourre-tout notre objectif je le répète
est de permettre l'adoption d'un texte
permettant de donner un nouveau souffle
à l'éthique sportifs et de renforcer
certains droits sportifs
je considère donc que l'article 30 n'a
pas sa place à notre texte
si la raison pour laquelle je vous
propose d'adopter cet amendement de
suppression je vous remercie
alors est-ce que ce point de vue est
partagé par notre rapporteur
et bien non monsieur le président je
rends un avis défavorable paquin car cet
article est très important pour fixer
enfin le droit à l'information en
matière de sport et donc la capacité des
français les moins fortunés avoir des
images importante dans leur discipline
préférée donc je le redis avis
défavorable madame la ministre
merci monsieur président confié aussi s
à l'édiction de règles relatives aux
conditions de diffusion des brefs
extraits permettrait trouver un juste
équilibre entre le droit à l'information
et le droit d'exploitation d'une
manifestation sportive et ce sujet
implique une forte concertation
notamment avec les diffuseurs que le csa
a déjà développé aujourd'hui
de plus la commission européenne nous
conteste que nous ayons correctement
transposé les dispositions de la
directive services de médias
audiovisuels sur les courts extraits et
c'est vrai que la jurisprudence que nous
avons conçu ce qui s'ils ne semble pas
être un moyen suffisant de transposition
aussi le fait de confier au csa la
responsabilité de la fixation des
conditions de diffusion des brefs
extraits apporterait une solution à ce
problème
c'est la raison pour laquelle
considérant que cette disposition relève
plutôt du droit à l'information
nous vous invitons à retirer votre
amendement alors président caudin
l'amendement numéro 16 et retiré alors
monsieur imbert reprend le l'amendement
7 rectifié de monsieur pozzo di borgo et
il devient l'amendement numéro 26 en
effet monsieur le président la maman de
précision utile donc je reprends un
d'accord bien aller l'avis du
gouvernement donc c'est un avis de
précision utile je le
donc deux avis favorables qui est pour
l'adopter quiconque qui s'abstient il
est adopté et l'article 30 ainsi amendé
utilement est adopté il est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'amande l'article 31
et c'est toujours le président yvon
collin qui nous présente un moment 17
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues à l'article
31 a lui aussi été introduit lors d'un
examen de notre proposition de loi en
commission il concerne je le rappelle la
prévention du dopage à la télévision
prévu par la loi du 30 septembre 1986
relative à la liberté de communication
la promotion de la lutte contre le
dopage au moment de la diffusion de
manifestations sportives à la télévision
n'a finalement jamais réellement été
appliquée par les chaînes de télévision
la raison de ces que ces derniers
évoquent invoque et notamment la
lourdeur du dispositif
pourtant la prévention de la lutte
contre le dopage par la diffusion de
messages à la télévision par et me
semble tout à fait pertinente
c'est un excellent moyen de
sensibilisation du public et en
particulier jeunes au problème du dopage
l'objectif l'article 30 et donc
d'assouplir les obligations prévues pour
les chaînes de télévision tout en
élargissant le champ de celles qui sont
concernées et en confirmant c'est ça de
pouvoir de mettre en oeuvre le
dispositif non conscient que ce
dispositif est tout à fait à sa place un
autre texte et nous remercions les
auteurs de l'amendement de l'avoir
proposé en effet il s'inscrit dans le
cadre du renforcement de la lutte contre
le dopage qui constitue un volet
fondamental de la proposition de loi
néanmoins nous vous proposons d'y
apporter une petite précision c'est la
raison pour laquelle cet amendement
réintroduit dans le texte proposé pour
l'article 23 de la loi du 30 septembre
1986 relative à la liberté de la
communication la référence explicite à
des programmes spéciaux relatifs à la
lutte contre le dopage et la protection
des sportifs
il s'agit donc d'un simple amende marc
de rescision que je vous demande bien
entendu d'adopter
monsieur rapporteur avis très favorable
c'est du très favorable et très
favorable du gouvernement
doc c'est du très favorable de notre
assemblée
il est adopté et l'article 31 ainsi
amende est adoptée dans les mêmes
conditions il est adopté
nous passons à l'examen de l'article 32
et là nous retrouvons la même
problématique que tout à l'heure avec
nous avons quatre amendements
suppression alors le premier n'est pas
défendu le 1 rectifié bis
jean françois voguet vous nous présentez
l'amendement numéro 5
mais monsieur le président un ministre
tout d'abord le procédé de validation
législative qui outrepasse une décision
de justice nous paraît contestable de
cette méthode qui a été utilisé pour
valider la concession grand stade après
son annulation par le tribunal
administratif
il s'agissait pour le législateur d'un
moyen de contourner les décisions
rendues par un tribunal
certes sous conditions mais néanmoins
cela constituait une certaine forme d'
atteinte au principe de séparation des
pouvoirs
garante de notre démocratie outre cette
procédure à nos yeux discutable il faut
noter que le conseil constitutionnel
saisi d'une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité a validé en février
dernier la validation de l'initiative ce
contrat de concession entre l'état et le
consortium stade de france 2 96 aussi en
introduisant cet art fait 32 dans cette
proposition de loi la commission évoque
l'importance économique du stade de
france pour légitimer une nouvelle
validation législative de ce même traité
de concession
pourtant ce n'est pas parce que le stade
de france est actuellement le stade sur
le stade notre ses 5 étoiles par l'ue
est fort et que les travaux sur ce ca
doivent être soit je vais en juin 2014
que ce contrat de concession de notre
être validée de cette manière nous avons
le temps si nécessaire pour une
validation réglementaire sont passés par
la loi un amendement identique avait été
déposé dans le cadre de la ppl uefa 2
16 et fort heureusement retirer le
gouvernement lui-même notre lisibilité
d'une telle décision
l'accueil des matches de l'euro 2016 au
stade de france ne serait pas remis en
cause par cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel le visait alors madame
la ministre des sports pour mémoire je
me permettrai de rappeler qu'à l'époque
de cette première validation législative
en 96 devant avant la coupe du monde de
football nous avions déjà alerté sur ce
bricolage législatif et nous avions
dénoncé les conditions financières que
celui ci fixe est depuis ce sont chaque
année plusieurs millions d'euros qui
sont versés au consortium grand stade et
ç'a pris sur le budget consacré au sport
le même que cette société n'est pas en
déficit
nous pensons donc que cette décision
doit plutôt être l'occasion de revoir
les termes du contrat de concession
respectant les intérêts des deux parties
c'est pourquoi nous demandons la
suppression de cet article alors
président colin renoue présenté
l'amendement numéro 15
mais monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
oui cet article 32 à lui aussi est
introduit en commission mais je eu
l'occasion de dire dans mon propos
liminaire à notre grand regret rappelé
que l'objectif de cet article est de
valider ça vient d'être dit le contrat
de concession entre l'état et le
consortium du stade de france pour le
financement la conception la
construction l'entretien et
l'exploitation de ce stade conclut dans
la précipitation le 29 avril 1995 ce
contrat dû être validé par la loi du 11
décembre 96 qui elle même a été déclarée
le rappelle au contraire à la
constitution par le conseil
constitutionnel février dernier
néanmoins cette décision n'entraîne pas
la nullité du dit contrat et sa
validation législative pourrait être
contestée et ainsi entraîner des
conséquences non négligeables sur les
finances de l'état alors sans entrer
dans la polémique sur le fond de ce
sujet il me semble que ce n'est ni le
lieu ni l'heure pour en débattre et
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure nous
souhaitons pas que notre proposition de
loi devienne texte portant diverses
dispositions sur le sport mais bien un
texte je le répète renforcer l'éthique
du sport et les droits des sportifs
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
propose d'adopter notre amendement
de suppression de l'article 32 je vous
remercie par avance et madame la
ministre a souhaité déposer un
amendement de suppression c'est sur
laquelle a demandé un scrutin public
merci monsieur le président
effectivement là comme les orateurs sur
les différents bancs de l'assemblée
l'ont rappelé à l'occasion d'une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité le conseil
constitutionnel a considéré que la loi
de 96 était contraire à la constitution
parce que c'est important de le
mentionner cette loi s'abstenait
d'indiquer le procès prises le motif
précis d'illégalité dont elle entend des
plongées l'acte contesté et donc que ce
faisant le législateur avait méconnu le
principe de séparation des pouvoirs
il ya en fait trois raisons de fond qui
nous amène à demander le retrait de ces
dispositions
la première c'est que la décision du
conseil constitutionnel n'entraîne pas
la nullité du contrat de concession qui
lie l'état au consortium et cette
analyse est validée par les services de
bercy est validée par le secrétariat
général du gouvernement
et d'ailleurs le conseil constitutionnel
a repris et valider l'existence du
contrat entre 96 et 2011 il n'a pas
remis en question
deuxièmement comme l'ont rappelé les
signataires de l'amendement numéro un
l'afer qui est à l'origine de cette
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité la ferme et nasser
contre le stade de france est
actuellement encore pendantes devant les
juridictions judiciaires et par
conséquent une intervention du
législateur pourrait être considérée
comme portant à nouveau atteinte à la
séparation des pouvoirs
enfin il n'est pas du tout certain
qu'une nouvelle disposition législative
qui validerait le contrat de concession
répondrait aux contres aux critères
définis par le conseil constitutionnel
en matière de loi de validation
comme vous le savez le cre était le
conseil constitutionnel exige qu'il y a
un motif d'intérêt général suffisant
motif qui peut être par exemple la
continuité du service public où la
menace pour la paix publique
un motif purement financier n'est pas en
lui-même recevable pour valider ce type
de contrat et nous tenons à
votre disposition une note du
secrétariat général du gouvernement qui
précise ses motifs
d'inconstitutionnalité
d'inconstitutionnalité je vous remercie
merci mam le ministre alors jean
françois humbert votre opinion sur ces
amendements
ça va être très rapide sagesse ce
président alors sagesse et je rappelle
que tout le monde et pour tout du moins
monsieur voguait le président colin et
le gouvernement pour supprimer cet
article
y at il une demande d'explication de
vôtre monsieur de montesquiou aymeri de
montesquiou
merci monsieur le président au même
liste je suis un peu surpris que la
commission ait voulu réintroduire une
convention qui est anticonstitutionnelle
déjà à l'automne 81,16 qu'en tant que
député je m'étais élevé contre l'anti
constitutionnalité de cette convention
je voudrais d'autre part souligné
qu'elle et léonine vis-à-vis de
certaines fédérations en particulier la
fédération française de rugby qui pour
ces raisons cherche à construire un
stade dans la région parisienne
je crois que il ya une meilleure façon
d'utiliser les deniers soit des
fédérations soit de l'état et en
conséquence je pense que la convention
qui lie l'état
les fédérations au stade de france doit
d'être remise à plat et renégocié n'ai
pas d'autres demandes
alors j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le gouvernement en
fait sur les trois amendements et je
vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission et sagesse l'avis du
gouvernement est favorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront aux secrétaires un bulletin
blanc contre un bulletin bleu
l'abstention a bulletin rouge le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
et je rappelle c'était trois amendements
de suppression de l'article
le scrutin est ouvert
eh bien le scrutin est clos et je
demande à messieurs les secrétaires a
procédé au dépouillement du scrutin
moi
alors résultats du scrutin numéro 2 119
sur l'amendement numéro 20 du
gouvernement de suppression de l'article
32 nombre de votants 300 ce nombre de
suffrages exprimés 196 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 99 pour
l'adoption 196 contre 0 le sénat a
adopté et l'article 32 est supprimé
alors on en revient à l'article 29 qui
étaient ceux qui étaient réservés
alors madame le ministre
si monsieur le président étant dédiée à
la suppression d'articles je vous
propose effectivement la suppression de
cet article et nous levons le gage alors
voilà c'était l'amendement 27
monsieur le rapporteur on est d'accord
bien alors explications de vote il n'y
en a pas donc l'article est supprimé je
le mets aux voix l'amendement de
suppression quai pour aller qui comptent
qui s'abstient et bien l'article est
supprimé je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote
alors jean jacques lozach je n'en vois
pas d'autre
vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues je voudrais
avant tout remercier le président yvon
collin et ses collègues du rds eux pour
l'occasion qui nous a été donné cet
après-midi de débattre des enjeux portés
par le sport je dirais le sport moderne
pour l'occasion qui nous a été donné
aujourd'hui de débattre de ce phénomène
de société en dehors de toute urgence
aux considérations d'actualité à froid
oserais-je dire cette proposition de loi
cette ppl réaffirme un certain nombre de
principes à cette énorme de valeur de
votre valeur morale de valeurs sociales
portée par l'activité sportive
en effet on peut dire que le sport est
une réalité très ambigu très paradoxale
très complexe
ça peut devenir comme disait europe à
propos de la langue les meilleure ou la
pire des choses suivant l'utilisation
que l'on en fait donc il nous appartient
nous puissance publique d'en prévenir et
combattre les dérives
il nous appartient d'en valoriser les
apports positifs pour le lien social
pour l'épanouissement individuel ou bien
encore pour le progrès économique et il
est bien évidemment essentiel de
l'inscrire dans le texte de loi mais
également de le décliner de manière
concrète et contractuelles notamment en
liaison avec le mouvement sportif
si nous regrettons que le plafonnement
de la masse salariale des clubs soient
soumis au bon vouloir des fédérations
sportives
vous n'en mesurons pas moins l'avancée
que constitue l'introduction d'un tel
principe dans notre code du sport
j'espère que l'audace de la fédération
de rugby en matière de régulation
économique et de transparence servira
d'exemple
maintenant que le salary cap bénéficie
d'une validation législative à notre
satisfaction nous sommes parvenus à
faire évoluer le dispositif de la
proposition de loi sur plusieurs points
notamment le maintien du pouvoir de
sanction administrative des fédérations
sportives qui constituait pour notre
groupe
l'un des enjeux majeurs l'un des enjeux
fondamentaux de ce texte
l'habilitation des échanges
d'informations entre la fld
et les agences les agences nationales
antidopage étrangères la possibilité
pour un effet l'idée de prendre des
mesures de sanction sur le fondement de
ces informations
néanmoins notre satisfaction est toute
relative nous avions conditionner notre
vote au sort réservé à l'amendement du
rapporteur sur le statut des sociétés
sportives
nous considérons son adoption dénature
la proposition de loi de nos collègues
du rdse je dirais la dénature
partiellement voilà alors à partir donc
de ces différentes considérations oui il
ya eu un petit moment je le concède la
table des ministres un petit moment de
flottement sur ce point très précis à
partir donc des avancées que vous avez
bien voulu accepter vous avez bien voulu
concéder
et bien je vous indique que sur cette
proposition de loi du groupe
rds le parti socialiste le groupe
socialiste pardon votre amour bien il
n'y a pas d'autres demandes
alors je vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi présentée par
le président yvon collin au nom du
groupe rds qui est pour adopter cette
proposition de loi qui est contre qui
s'abstient au crc spg
cette proposition de loi est adopté
ordre du jour du mardi à pardon excuses
m'en excuser moi président non monsieur
le président mais chez madame la
ministre mes chers collègues simplement
remercier toutes celles et tous ceux qui
se sont associés
d'abord en amont travail pour préparer
cette ppl remercier bien sûr
jean-françois de ceux du travail qu'il a
accompli à la tête de la commission jean
françois maire a fait un travail énorme
il a été à notre à notre écoute et à
celle de la commission vous remercier
madame le ministre et ses services qui
ont été d'un précieux secours
effectivement aussi dans la préparation
de cette de cette ppl
je crois qu'elle a donné lieu à un débat
très très serein c'est vrai que
elle disait tout à l'heure que le sport
ne vient pas assez souvent en discussion
dans cet hémicycle et je partage
j'ai entendu j'ai bien entendu aussi que
certains auraient souhaité une loi plus
fondatrice plus importantes on peut
toujours faire plus
effectivement mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons fait si
longtemps grand pas mais on a fait un
pas important pour renforcer l'éthique
du sport nous savons tous dans nos
collectivités combien la vie associative
la vie sportive joue un rôle important
prépondérant on sort on doit à la
jeunesse d'avoir un moment sportif qui
soit exemplaire et bien cette cette loi
qui contribuera par cette charte éthique
à l'image des du rubis monsieur aymeri
de montesquiou l'a rappelé et des sports
de combat qui ont déjà qu'ils ont été en
avant je crois que là nous avons franchi
un grand pas sur le dopage également il
s'agissait de renforcer le dispositif
même si la france ça a été dit et répété
est en avance là-dessus sur ce sur ce
sujet enfin sur certains aspects
financiers je pense au salary cap
on peut aussi effectivement peut-être
aller plus loin et j'ai été sensible à
votre amendement même si je me suis
abstenu sur sept enfants de ma mais je
crois qu'il faut aller plus loin
madame la ministre vous avez du travail
là pour le porter plus loin pour faire
prospérer comme on dit cette ppl à
l'assemblée nationale je l'espère très
bientôt
et puis pour effectivement au niveau
européen faire progresser cette idée des
tic de lutte contre le dopage et enfin
une moralisation financière des clubs
voilà en tout cas nous avons franchement
pas je voudrais du fond du coeur vous
remercier à toutes et à tous de ce grand
moment républicain comme pour le service
civique
il ya des instants parfois où nous
savons nous retrouver sur des textes et
c'est toujours des moments très
agréables
merci à toutes et à tous vous venez de
suivre l'adoption de la proposition de
loi du groupe rdse sur l'éthique dans le
sport pour revoir cette séance notre
site internet publicsenat.fr
je vous retrouve cet après midi à partir
de 17 heures pour la séance de questions
cribles thématiques consacrées
aujourd'hui à la politique audiovisuelle
française très belle journée à tous